is the one just about to come out it was
ideas games that are view going on later
today
[ __ ]
it's fine yeah what's wrong with your
hair yeah what is that side it looks
okay but from this side beside that
Alison yeah yeah I said I look fine yeah
Rob didn't say anything that's the real
test
[Music]
ah
last night was so stupid
you bring that up you know you have to
talk about yeah what happened not
nothing that life yeah that wasn't the
dumb you might think I was there longer
because I was there freely
it was it was skin pack
because of the game
[Applause]
the thinned-out later
had a guy yelling and my dear the whole
time I was
this is friends two feet away from
that's super turned away from me though
yeah can we rotate it a little bit more
so Kelly it's like facing center
that's not for you okay I don't need to
see people not know about me
yo Richard Richard can we rotate the
monitor a little bit you okay
fun time for me yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no I didn't know he didn't huh you dude
what are you doing oh my god tappy tap
[ __ ] she says she's a little bad but
you're laughing injustice is coming up
you see is it they haven't said anything
about that uh no yeah but I'm aware of
oh wow that was a slap yes love mm-hmm
yes I'm a girl
can you talk will you be okay for an
hour and a half we'll be talking I just
like talk like this didn't want to know
what you did
[Applause]
Seto's
[Music]
for life subdued it I heard what you
said the first time yeah we all
okay guy in camphor get off your phone
and get back to work that's usually good
to the point where like nothing about
you back to work
it's to the point where during meetings
Chris will stop talking and just stare
at John Luke until he puts his phone
away
really yeah as you Luke CPA Channel
Jumma Bella is a new kitty on your
office phone look at what he'll look at
it in two seconds
he's what facial expression we can't
hear it he could tell you just looking
straight at the camera but there is plus
to him they hated you probably texting
all of us saying [ __ ] you yeah check
your phones
nope it's a head of Georgia yeah say hi
to all the Georgia say hi to Tallahassee
that's Florida
[ __ ] [ __ ] I mean jeez hey I've been
trying not to correcting come on dude so
maybe we ever that has to be have some
sort of reaction ah damn we are live
about five minutes 24 seconds I'd say um
I didn't bring the giveaway and again
because I don't like doing that oh I
know what it is
little nightmares six edition which
didn't make sense so I found out that
six is the main character sick
where's ps4 stand for please stop for
stop Carl the winner says hi folks
I love Carl hmm I'm an uncle Omkar from
Davis California that's kind of close to
here right yeah yeah I was like the
college there yeah UC Davis I drove by
there when I went to Tahoe this weekend
we know we're live and we know that
we're super boring the show is not
started yet
actually stopped having the table sigh
yeah I think it's I watch this link
Hobbs hmm thank you for listening to me
Kelly watch this movie called meltdown
last night is a Jet Li movie that I used
to own on like a bootleg Chinese like
VCD not even DVD and it appeared on
Netflix and I watched it I didn't
remember what the movie really was it's
basically a Hong Kong version of die
hard oh yeah
and it's super over-the-top like really
like melodramatic like erring on the
side of comedy kind of acting and events
and stuff horribly edited infinitely
entertaining really good and there's
this guy who so gently plays a cop whose
family died like during a mission where
he wasn't able to save them so he goes
into a life of like being a bodyguard
for a movie star and this movie star is
like if Jackie Chan was known for
wearing Bruce Lee's outfit but also
being a horrible drunk and womanizer
like the idea that Jackie Chan never
uses a stunt double is like one of this
guy's mo but because he's always drunk
he does use a stunt double and they go
all these lengths to like hide that from
people watch the meltdown on Netflix and
it's good what it's good
it's called what was that Nicholas Cage
movie were trying to ascribe to me
though Rach I finally saw that again the
image for that movie sucks
I saw synopsis sighs it for me
taken with Nicolas Cage but like far
worse writing worse acting Chris Pratt
and Jeff oh yeah horribly boring intro
yeah the ending was so bad in that
trailer I just told you guys there's
where he has the joystick and he's like
using the robot to give her a letter
like that that joystick is a thruster a
logitech joystick that I have and it's
like one most popular joysticks it's
like flying on 20 bucks
it's like all they did was like put a
different button on it yeah it's like
future hilarious no ending was like like
offensively bad yeah well no passengers
is that Chris Pratt no I just yeah I've
heard nothing but bad things about that
it looks it wasn't like unwatchable bad
it's like King Arthur this weekend that
was unwatched why'd you see that my
friend wanted to see it how is it still
messed up because everyone says it's
awful it's is everything everything is
bad it's like it's Guy Ritchie times 10
no my friend described it as a 12 year
old directed all the fight the fight
scenes but the only movie that 12 year
old had ever seen was 300 dang hard so
yeah so passengers was better than that
woof woof
whoa bark or sniffed our spin this if
our audience loves yeah we're not just
Muir mics it's like I just watch it just
look at our face what used to be right
yeah I think I'm gonna have to
pull my phone out later for Twitter
stuff so deal with that as you will okay
okay
don't like like throw it some uh
remaining for space to there's some one
of those space pens they're all obsessed
with like in the Seinfeld or whatever
it'll like write upside down right any
temperature the dinky looking pen but
feel like I'm Jersey you know that um
like common thing people are like oh the
the u.s. spent a bunch of money to get a
pen that work in space and the Russians
used a pencil and just like oh it's the
simplest answer is usually the best one
yeah
but also lead splinters and it's really
bad for the equipment so Penn was sort
of important so uh combo cool facts and
I put in one space
face is cool I like space Richard
Garriott who we interviewed recently
used his the money he made from games to
start six different companies in the
interest of getting himself to space he
finally did he doesn't eat did Lord the
name Ward Britisher
hey welcome everyone to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here Wednesday mornings every week I'm
Mike McCarty your host here with Pete
brown stop tapping the table Nick sorry
I'm fidgety today what's up dude
nothing I'm fidgeting today I can't talk
straight that's all right
I'm gonna take this moment if I can hold
on a second no I'm here with Rob handler
as well
hi and Kelly Peggy hello returning
guests do your spiel what do you want I
could promote a review I'm putting up
live later we do this real quick some of
you may have seen this retro HD from
hypercam $40 HDMI supported NES console
we're the only one that has one we got
our view going live this afternoon
that's all I got we the only one we're
the only what that has one the only one
oh I thought you meant like I was like
you're not we your you the Royal you
yeah um we're we were talking about
Trump earlier about whether he's gonna
get impeached yet or what's this deal
with Paul Ryan either way he's screwed I
don't know yeah they're they're looking
to move those steps I guess you got me
[ __ ] politics for an hour talk politics
wasn't there for this Trump conversation
yeah uh I did Batman Russia a little bit
like a couple minutes ago that you
vented about Russia badmouth Russia
another stupid space pencil got lead and
all the equipment oh that's right you
did
weren't you uh what did I say to you
today that you took the wrong way oh I
said I was gonna punch your doughnut he
ordered a doughnut at the cafe up front
and so Oleg ER and he and I said and he
said something like oh hey Mike how are
you know you said something means that
I'm gonna punch your dona and he took it
as a euphemism but anyway uh if you're
joining us on Twitter or YouTube we have
the chats up here as always so feel free
to join in I got some Twitter replies
for questions about games we're talking
about later we have a lot of games this
week to talk about it's a lot like
there's a couple big ones but it's also
a lot of kind of under the radar ones
that we wanted to give some love but as
usual first I wanted to talk about our
giveaway little nightmares if you
haven't played it yet we have Xbox one
and ps4 the sixth edition which is the
figure of the main character as well
with the game but it's only in North
America apologies to anybody outside of
off the continent outside of the
continent we some of some legal stuff
but Shiva who runs our Twitter account
in the twitch chat will put the link if
you don't follow GameSpot on Twitter
please do so and then retweet the
giveaway tweet and then later in the
week we'll pick a random person to give
one copy of ps4 and then another person
for the Xbox one copy that is little
Nightmares some news items apparently
according to a report from The Wall
Street Journal because I read The Wall
Street Journal there's a new Zelda and
Pokemon game coming to mobile makes
sense right there weren't really too
many details outside of that there's a
lot of news this week about games that
don't have any details uh Pokemon was
that was card base card base yeah is it
like a deck building game wall well
there's a no c'mon trading card game
there's Jim Lee well extension of that
there's already a trading card game
online but I think it's kind of janky so
if they like refurbished it that would
be cool but I don't know how it work on
phones it's right now it's on um like
tablets and PC
we got like hearthstone and stuff that
works on phones yeah well I can figure
it out
who knows if they'll figure that out
what about the Zelda games like an
endless runner god I hope so yeah
like Lara Croft Link's crossbow training
or no Lara Croft go was not an endless
runner that was the like the tile-based
thing that games fun the puzzle game um
halo 6 won't be at e3 apparently
according to Microsoft and 343 and then
also they decried rumors about no they
didn't decry them denied rumors about
Halo 3 being remastered it will not at
least as of now so for those of you
hoping to see halo 63 may be able to
wait a little longer or will have to
wait a little longer I think well what
if they now something before e3
everything of that will have a trailer
yeah right they have to have no I don't
think they're gonna talk about it would
be no no 683 there's nothing yeah
nothing I don't know how they but that
could be a really good sign that might
mean they have something else that's
super cool that they want to parade in
front of people that's not just Scorpio
and I would say it's also a good sign I
personally I don't want another
remastered halo 2 or halo 3 if anything
it says that they're maybe they're
putting a lot more attention into this
follow up Halo game right yeah it could
be I think maybe crackdown is going to
be like one of their showcase things
what else do they have see if thieves
sports IG thieves yeah but is that even
like they see if thieves
seems like they're going for some sort
of like emergent gameplay within this
pirate setting which sounds cool but
from what I've seen I don't see them
flushing it out enough to do that I've
heard good things up thinking like I
heard it was fun so it's in closed beta
like whatever something like that yeah
early access of some sort and Ubisoft
dropped a whole news deuce on us this
week far cry 5 is confirmed there's not
there aren't many details outside of you
laughing at that the comment sorry
far cry 5 is confirmed rumors and then
Assassin's Creed origins as well
it's rumored to be a reboot of the
series of some sort you were saying Hina
yeah like the message the image that
leaked showed the character with a bow
on a boat yeah and but like it I don't
know is like here that said make history
right its original yeah stay tuned for
more at this year's e3 so SAS is Creed
origins far cry 5 and the crew 2 was
also announced so like everything
possible that Ubisoft could have
announced outside of a lot of other
things they will also all release before
March 31st of next year that is not a
random date that's the end of their
fiscal year and they said it will
release this fiscal year but that is it
for what do you want fire craft 5 to go
do you like far cry games Pete I don't
play a lot of them I respect them what
do I want from it I don't know you know
where do you know where you'd want it to
be set because what for was like the
Himalayas I believe Tibet 3 was an
island tropical 2 was African jungle of
Blanes the rumor was Wild West right
yeah cuz there was that TV spot that
people said they're shooting on in Hana
the local newspaper reported that they
were doing a TV TV spot but like Montana
could be other things it's new Alice
thought the rumors that it was also Red
Dead Redemption that's that's what I
thought too but it would be a
live-action trailer but no they
specifically said the person directing
it was it was a West oh so I have no
idea what that is anymore but Far Cry 5
I want it to be I know where I'd want it
to be because I like Far Cry primal more
than a lot of people I think that game
was actually kind of underrated I know
it's kind of
spinoff and it got [ __ ] for being a
reskin farcry but I liked it
thought they stuck to their prehistoric
guns so to speak they didn't really I
thought I mean I think I thought they
would just introduce these like
machine-gun rock thrower or something to
deviate from the slower more tense pace
that it established at the beginning but
they stuck to it throughout the game and
I liked it um cool we have a lot of
games to talk about today and you know
so little time but we will be talking
about injustice to black ops 3 zombie
Chronicles DLC Fire Emblem echoes what's
the end of that shadows of Valencia
sounds of Valencia Valencia it sounds
like an STD of Fire Emblem Gaiden yes
okay um maybe dreadnought you were
playing the closed beta we'll get into
that because I know you like the game I
like that game the surge which is from
the developer of Lords the Fallen and
Farpoint the VR shooter hmm
let's start there you played Farpoint I
did play for a point I played like an
hour and a half yesterday um we want to
know what how does it work as a VR sugar
because most of time those are not good
right you have like an actual controller
gun really it feels pretty good the
movement you have basically movement on
two sticks one is like your actual walk
forward left and right starts raving but
then one of the back is like it's like
where your his right arm is is basically
your adjustment of turning so if you you
don't really actually have to use your
headset so much to turn all the way
around you can actually use a controller
regardless it is a station move though
don't you you do I forget how much the
packages but what's really neat is that
you really are aiming down sights like a
red dot scope and you find yourself
closing your left I was waiting for it
yeah that's my guys anything
no so it's what you find yourself doing
that when you kill one of like the
bigger aliens and it's dead and you just
have a shotgun and like an assault rifle
very much like a uh like the halo battle
rifle um but like you know after a fight
you really just get shocked and you just
keep shooting his guts until explodes
it's pretty satisfying yeah there's more
about you
how do you mind yeah I was gonna say
that's uh does the movement sorry Mike
there's no feeling on your face after
you said that yeah just talked about
shooting his guts and then when deadpan
I have my jaw hurts I'm trying to my
anyway my serial killer does uh cuz I
get like motion sick its sickness like a
lot in VR um especially with movement
with a stick
like an analog stick so did you prefer
one of it over the other no it's fine I
didn't feel sick at all I know I know
you mean right with the heavy movement
type games where you're like flying
around I want to say you can you can
have that sickness feeling but for the
most part it's really generous like
again like you can kind of you could
really just not even move your head and
really have all control in the
controller itself as far as movement and
looking so you know it's one of those
instances works like I'm looking around
I find myself now here and I'm walking
straight you can readjust I'm talking
with the controller if it feels good
regardless yeah it feels good as a
shooter it works really well as far as
the game itself it it got very Arkady
and boring for me at least like do you
there's a there is a narrative story
where it's like yeah here's it's it
reminds me of like a split between like
Starship Troopers in a stellar uh and
like Mars was the last Mars movie with
Matt Damon Martian Martian um it's Bill
Martian it's nice there's a Martian I
don't know it's reversed
excuse me mr. Martian I suppose as far
as the game like it's just it's very
basic if you move around assured you
might have said this sticks the sticks
okay so the killer has analog sticks
mechanically it's strong but there's
just like not a lot there to give it
yeah you're shooting yeah you're
shooting and the the aliens become
repetitive as far as like the waves like
it just it feels very like rudimentary
just like okay like these guys I know I
handled like it's freaky oh like you
have like those face crawler type guys
so it's like you're doing a lot of like
shooting at them in midair before they
like hit your face
did you try playing without the gun I
don't even know if you can just moves
just a move does not by default come
with that gun oh wow
so you can buy this game and play it
with a dual shock for oh and if you did
some hot periphery before it would be
but very much like a state without the
VR feature of it it is a is a very
boring game in my opinion and you would
still play this in VR technically but
yeah you don't have that thing right
it's really neat and it feels great like
it's just excellent recommendation
doesn't do it for you we are live
streaming the game at 2 p.m. today
Nick margarita and Nick margarita will
be live streaming that game and right
you can check that out and Ritchie here
one of our social video guys and our
review will be going live probably
shortly before that as well okay so if
you want to know more about Farpoint
who's reviewing that for us freelancer
justin clerk okay freelancer Justin
Clark his review will be up soon uh Rob
actually while we're talking about games
that you have played recently what about
dreadknot yeah so might people this kind
of under the radar yeah what's the
what's the elevator pitch for dreadknot
it is i just think of destiny when I
hear dread not so it is a wait why cuz
there's a dread oh yeah not sahaja
that's where my brain goes it is a MOBA
styled
spaceship like I want to say shooter but
yeah it's it's cool it's neat you get
anything from like a fast-moving
Corvette ship to do like hidden run or
you get your huge giant cruisers like
this or you get a glass cannon styled
sniper it's very team centric you have a
healer ship that plays a very integral
role like if you just if you basically
heal your team that's a successful team
yeah it's not a dogfighting game it's
mutts naval combat it's also much slower
paced but a good way you know it's more
about these the hulking ships of the
Navy duking it out it's really fun I
really like this game it doesn't it's
weird in this case it watching it
doesn't really do justice in my opinion
it's intense you can get in these really
neat showdowns
and barely get out of it and then you
know you have like again your healer
class can come and like save the day
uh you the the neat part is you're doing
a lot of power management so you have
your shields you have your basically a
damage boost for your weapons and you
have a speed boost and on the right
there the HUD you can see the meter
going up and down so in situations are
here like all right now I'm just gonna
go all out on my weapons and take this
guy down
but then enemy ship might come up behind
you I'm going to shift it to shields so
you'reyou're doing this really neat
power management thing which is very
much what you like to think of any kind
of spaceship even movie you know it's
like all power to shields and all that
stuff like the Star Trek style that's
really fun it's it's fun to manage that
on the fly and what's neat is so this is
a ps4 so I got to play on ps4 closed
beta the touchpad is where this
management comes and it's it's pretty
intuitive it's nice it feels pretty good
I would say what's frustrating is that
the same touchpad is also used for
commands and talking so if you press
down on the touchpad I tell you like
engage with your team so a couple times
I would by myself like accidentally
calling for help or some like that I did
because it's all you'd it's a light
touch on the touchpad but yeah it's fun
it's time to look out for this gonna be
free-to-play which is I guess a plus so
anyone can kind of dive into it it
follows the free-to-play model if I
could compare to anything to like war
thunder or workroom we're frame yeah
sure no I mean the plain game I'm
matching the playing game as far as you
can you put money into I think they were
like hero ships you can buy credits to
spacely speed up your research tree so
you can do all that in game but you can
speed it up and get to the other ships
you have to unlock ships as you go on
you can't just like say all that [ __ ]
let's go on get that you have to unlock
the previous ships in the tree it's
developed by jäger yeah I made spec ops
the line back in what 2009 was that 2010
mmm knows after 2000 2000 12 2011 I
don't know but yeah if you play back up
the line as the same developer not the
writers anymore actually writers backups
Alliance do in Battlefront 2 but
yeah this is worth checking out it's not
typically my typically my kind of game
but I had a lot of fun with it when I
played on PC about a year ago I meant to
check it out on ps4 did not get the
chance but your recommendations
definitely have me interested okay don't
release date yet there is not I believe
it just hit open beta on PC so you can
check it out if you have yourself a PC
and try it out still not available like
for full retail on PC no no because you
know I saw this game years years ago we
went just down the street into their
like but their current or affiliate
video here a month after you started
even yeah it was I think it was and we
apply myself after I start we saw their
early stages and what's funny is like
I'm one I love spaceships dad you huge
giant slow moving things and you could
just so hot it is hot it's hot and
worked up I'm not worked up you love
giant slow moving things in general yeah
yeah dinosaurs yeah I love my ex-wife
Wow
so I it's there there's a lot of heart
and like their designs and their models
and stuff and it's it's it's like a core
like passion you could tell and I think
it's really neat cool yeah I want to
check it out
I played the Serge today which I didn't
even know was a thing until someone
brought it up last week oh okay um it's
by Lord of the Fallen developer in it 13
Dec 13 you know that's kind of a it is a
Dark Souls clone and this very much is
as well but it's post-apocalyptic kind
of futuristic exoskeleton vibes and I
was playing it this morning
I like it it's got more to do with
targeting specific limbs so you come up
against other people in EXO suits and
it's weird there I have you know I'm
nitpicking this a lot but the review for
this will be up later Daniel snarky live
now it's live now if you want to go read
about it after the show but you can see
you're highlighting certain parts of the
body if you want to hit an armored part
of their body obviously you won't do as
much damage they'll be harder to kill
but you gets more spare parts if you hit
armored parts but if you see a nun
armored like their head or there are
more specific limb you'll kill them
faster you pick up these tech parts that
are kind of your souls so to speak
in this game and you get different
weapons this is the I was using a vibro
blade later on as far as I like picking
a certain area on their suit can you
like disable like their gun here or
something like that or I want to stable
it once you destroy it you get this
finishing option you have to hold square
to whatever you're playing on square or
X to finish them off and then you get
more supplies from that there's a lot of
inventory management this game you get
implants neural implants to kind of buff
your character you pick between two
classes right the beginning one is the
Lynx one is the Rhino I picked the Lynx
more a kind of a blood-borne II fast
character and then the Rhino is more in
legend it is I think they're fighting a
rhino right here but yeah everybody else
you come up against it's really really
hard to read enemy attacks because
they're all like told Pete it's like
drunken boxing it's not they don't
Telegraph things the same way they might
in Dark Souls or even lures the Fallen
it's this swinging kind of really like
they're moving through molasses and you
don't even I didn't even know they were
attacking me until my health dropped it
takes some getting used to and I it's
weird if it wasn't for the fact there's
so many other games I might actually
keep going with us because it's
satisfying my eternal Dark Souls it and
it's still you know about finding
shortcuts back to med Bay's which is
where you upgrade your character and
there's gear assembly right near it it's
more about you know finding shortcuts
back to there and managing your
resources one system that barrier yeah
the chair you sit in then the
communication terminal and the gear
assembly right nearby you get a lot of
parts to make new parts but you you get
different armor for each limb you get
new weapons does it do anything like in
that Dark Souls II formula that's unique
or is it just something that you like
because you want to keep playing a Dark
Souls like it's it doesn't I mean the
targeting limbs is probably the most
unique thing it does although I've only
played an hour what you were saying our
freelancer and our review daniel stark
you're saying it does some different
things later on but there's like weird
platforming apparently later on the game
yeah he was well he was saying that was
one of the missteps he did like the
targeting aspect of it but you can only
jump when you're running and he was
saying that there's times when it's yeah
platforming it's kind of simple to just
Crudup because the game is a little bit
awkward that's weird like clumsy with
that yeah it's well I was like uh if I'm
not mistaken I believe you could only
could you jump in Dark Souls without
yeah I guess you could kind of but yeah
I wouldn't want a platformer in a game
like this so that kind of deters me a
little bit but I also don't it the
opening I don't get what's going on in
the story yes sir no I have no idea they
have an intro that gets right into it
it's weird you uh you get off this rail
system and you're in a wheelchair and
you go and pick you have to apply for a
job as the Rhino XO or the Lynx eggs oh
and then I think something between then
and this happened and you must have been
in a coma or something but you have the
exosuit and then past that I stopped
listening to what was going on story I
have no idea there it started off with
this one this like CEO of a startup cRIO
talking to you and it was really
annoying I don't want see his face or
here yeah it was just it's the kind of
person that I've run into in San
Francisco and then I was about to say
we're just going to saturate with that
kind of person
oh that was pretty neat yeah the facial
moves are really cool they're neato
stylish oh yeah I'm just I'm see if I
yeah see you can target the head then
you get horizontal or vertical attacks
different weapons will have different
speeds I prefer to faster weapon because
I was dodging a lot here's a finishing
move Bam Bam so he targeted a specific
limb that fell off most you have better
chances of getting gear that way but yes
weirdly Bhushan Ryu cat was saying I
think recore was supposed to be this
game or something it does seem like when
you're in the exterior environments it
looks like reek or in terms of the in
terms of the the world itself that was
the one game it reminded me of as far as
kind of that kind of post-apocalypse or
whatnot but uh yeah I don't know I do
what did we give this review wise uh
I'll top my head I think was a seven
okay so it's a good game I might keep
playing a little more Erik Kay was
checking it out he's a big fan of
blood-borne Dark Souls I don't think he
liked Lords of the Fallen that much but
yeah if you're interested in Dark Souls
clones try this out see if it does
anything unique for you alright another
game this week that I have not gotten a
chance to play yet as Fire Emblem echos
shadow of Valencia Valencia shadow or
shadows shadows of Al India there's
multiple shadows there's multiple echos
kind of way those work fireable minutes
morality uh hit me whether you play like
five hours
yeah um which so there's about six
chapters in the game and I've played
almost to the end of the first one and
they really don't know what we're doing
um so past Fire Emblem games on 3ds
right they incorporated a lot of almost
dating sim like aspects yeah which is
enjoyable you know in its own way but
this game doesn't really have much of
that it's based on a game as Kelly
mentioned called Fire Emblem Gaiden
which came out on the original Nintendo
Famicom in Japan one of the earliest
firm it's one of the earlier firewood
tanks smell of mold permeate a shrine
that's dank so one of the things you
just saw and you're currently looking at
is this third person exploration so for
the most part in this game which let me
just wrap up that last part there's no
relationship building in the traditional
sense of Fire Emblem good so separate
eyes with everyone so essentially the
gameplay flow works as you move along a
map with like a linear path and there's
a couple branches that go off and you
can explore dungeons or bump into
enemies and get to tactical battles the
tactical battles are very familiar for
what most people are used to for from
Fire Emblem recently they've changed a
few mechanics so you can't pair two
people on the same tile now but there's
also no more weapon triangle so you're
not going to have like advantages or
disadvantages based on the specific
category of weapon right there's more
like um like weapon degradation
management and stuff like that rather
than notice there's not rot yes alright
there's more um there now I'm blanking
on what our reviewer had this excellent
paragraph all about like all the cool
changes and like departments from modern
Fire Emblem and yeah like your inventory
is very important yeah the inventory
management is kind of one of the more
strategic elements then if you're used
to modern Fire Emblem kind of like that
spear sword axe matchup triangle
precisely yeah it's got a few other
things going for it like it allows you
to rewind time
during battles you have you know limited
uses based on something that you earn
but that's kind of interesting for a
game like this especially if you play
with perma death now like if you play
with perma death you're kind of supposed
to just you know deal with it when
people die like most normal people
though we can't just you know let that
happen so we want to restart our old
save and not that let that person die
but this game can just let you rewind a
few turns I rather then start all over
again that's the coolest thing to me is
like you can obviously opt not to use it
but it's it's going to ease that like
soft resetting thing that a lot of us do
with Fire Emblem if you play with perma
death but also you have to manage
because you only have a limited amount
of rewinds you have to manage it like
you could rewind because you didn't get
like a good rng on whatever hit you did
or you could rewind to save a character
and you kind of have to make that call
yeah
and you know sort of because the
relationships are out of this there's a
huge focus primarily on the story which
kind of sets the tone for the game which
is it makes it like less lighthearted
than most fire mom games are like you
know mission to mission there are
conversations you can have with people
during combat which to me personally
feel a little bit weird because there's
people trying to kill you and you're
just like joking with your friend about
some like old you know like thing you
guys have in common don't every single
voice - like a lot of it most of it yeah
I can't think of anything that wasn't
yeah so pretty much and again you know
the third person dungeon exploration
stuff it's pretty basic but it's not as
unwieldy as it might seem for a series
that has never really had that before
yeah that's my biggest question cuz I
like I've seen gameplay obviously like I
read the review I am not quite sure how
that exploration works this sounds like
it's a it's a positive thing for the
game like it provides variety but like
definitely are you doing so the three
things you can do during the game when
you're moving along the overworld map is
bump into an enemy and get in combat go
to a town and use almost like
point-and-click searching to like find
items and talk to people but then you
will come across dungeons as well and so
you sort of enter those from the map but
you go to it you click on it and then
it's just a third-person thing and
you're kind of exploring it's not a huge
space
in the stuff that I've seen so far
you'll find items you'll bump into
enemies when you bump into an enemy it
breaks out into that typical you know
overhead 2d Fire Emblem battle system
it's it's not groundbreaking like it
certainly is an inventive like compared
to so many other games that are
dungeon-crawling RPGs but it does help
make this feel like a distinct fire
emblem for sure which I felt like fates
the biggest gimmick was the fact that
there are three versions of the game
yeah it was almost more of an annoyance
if anything it was a big thing where
it's like because I know a lot of people
who skipped birth right because they
were Fire Emblem veterans than you guys
like missed that piece of faith and you
go to conquest a revelation whereas it's
nice to have something that you know is
standalone at least and something that's
more strategy focused of course I'm
bummed because I really like the
relationship stuff in recent Fire Emblem
games and in in any game so but I do
appreciate having a it seems like more
focused especially because it's focused
on what two characters and their respect
for armies yeah and frankly it's you
know it honors kind of fire emblems
roots as well so it's yeah it might
upset a few people who are more used to
the the you know today's fire emblem
stuff but I think for folks like myself
especially like I kind of enjoy just a
focus on the political conflict and the
military skirmishes and that kind of
thing XCOM to was one of my favorite
games last year and in terms of the
stripping the relationship things from
this I make the comparison just because
it's the turn-based kind of a more
strategic overhead kind of stuff do you
think I'll be interested in this be
coming from that background I think you
will I don't think like wow little I've
played of XCOM 2 I see there being very
more depth to the variables that you
have to manage in battle mm-hmm this one
is a little bit more straightforward
um I think you'll still like it though I
mean thematically it's interesting early
on like the game sort of presents this
intro story where it shows these two
characters as kids and their friends and
they're happy but when you start the
game the first thing you see in the
cutscene is one of them stabbing the
other one through the chest and the
other one missing on
like Jesus like what the hell happened
so what kinds you know and then go back
to the grid yeah
uh yeah cuz you're managing two armies
throughout the game right and one of
them leads to each of those yeah we gave
it a 9 out of 10 it's up the reviews on
game Spira now if you want to go look at
it you also wrote in the notes DLC model
is dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign
insane dollar sign dollar sign dollar
sign that is the one cloud hanging over
this game it's a forty dollar 3ds game
the season pass for the DLC which i
think is like five packs which probably
includes a couple maps in a few items
$45 damn more than the game itself
what's the game for word oh I remember
when you you were like yeah cuz Peter
sits across from me so you think we're
like what the hell is very sweet about
it didn't you yeah of course you did of
course I did I love tweeting yeah you
don't tweet that much I was I got my
timeline last night I don't take that
much you don't really you were too busy
polishing your retro consoles don't make
me say it yeah firemen uh is echoes I
think is a really good game we have a
question about it um let me pull my
phone up quick so I can go to Twitter in
general somewhat saying do you think it
do you think there is a fire emblem
fatigue now there are three games the 3s
that's from Lloyd Christmas I'm feeling
it a little bit and yes that name is
amazing so you do think there's some
fatigue setting in I am feeling it a
little bit um but I think it's almost
more in my head than like a real thing
is when I'm actually playing the game
I'm still really engaged in it you know
yeah like uh even playing Heroes on
mobile yeah I was like it just made me
want to play awakening like I I didn't
get tired of it yeah yeah that's just I
don't know I can't be satisfied with
fire it's I mean it's definitely
interesting because they're doing things
differently than the other games that
we've seen that does help mix up things
so that the fatigue isn't as bad as it
might seem what about the fire emims on
the switch when Mata do we know anything
about it nope you know you know my jaws
tie was saying based on the information
we have on fireman switch should we
expect a return to form with that or
will follow the current 3ds standards I
guess I don't I'm not privy to
information hmm there
on those games aren't tied down to the
double screen like on 3ds are they uh no
that just sort of provides you like a
supplemental menu screen that you can
feel like stats for yeah yes stuff like
that yeah yeah cool
all right well like I said our view is
up on GameSpot Heidi Kemp's right our
freelance I gave it a 9 out of 10 go
read that if you want more in-depth
information I'm gonna be playing it
later today
Jake Decker is pretty pissed that I have
it because he likes fireman games a lot
about Friday right yes the 19th people
are talking about Fire Emblem warriors
which is different from the Fire Emblem
game on switch that we're talking about
yeah fireman warriors is the new so
right and then there's a different right
there's an intelligence sustainable yeah
Fire Emblem yeah yeah burn button
matching dynasty Warriors move so kind
of stuff right yeah okay um yeah moving
on to you to yesterday at Kelly and Robb
played a lot of nazi zombies
well I mean well first few Maps you're
Nazis right there's some Nazis kino der
toten mm-hmm
knocked out on totin and when I can't
even pronounce that I still can't
pronounce after yesterday ver baroque
Fraulein the one that starts with a V
Bob Sherman tell me your thoughts on
this eight map DLC for black ops 3 not
if it works yeah so basically it's a
remastered classic zombies maps for
black ops 3 which I mean like that's
kind of a cool reason to go back to like
I'm sorry especially if you weren't a
big fan of infinite right we're fair
zombie a silently yes you're going to
need to have a copy of black ops 3 um
yeah it's not standalone shot 30 bucks
and then it's 30 bucks what about a cool
standalone thing like have all the maps
how many are there uh well it's all
Treyarch nazi zombies I keep saying nazi
zombies but they deviate from that after
the first few but these are Nazis right
here it's all Treyarch right it includes
yet it's a world at war black ops 1 and
black ops 2 zombies maps um some of our
like yeah the UH kino der toten uh no
I'm butchering that name but that is
such a great map waiting back to i
didn't you we used your claw I was like
I didn't play this no yeah
was are you playing on mics Rob yeah you
were having I was a [ __ ] like this
till decimation I did
I think we're watching Jake play kdr
this is this is the oh this might be
Jake playing that's right um yeah we had
um Jason Jason Blunden Blundell's scuse
me and um sounds like an ad last name
Blunden bling wind but yeah it was cool
to hear him talk about the classic maps
and like even how zombies was created
was was pretty interesting as far as
they basically were messing around with
the flamethrower in world of war on just
like enemy basic enemy AI you know like
a like a white test setting and it was
pretty fun and then next thing I guess
they said as they were having fun with
uh you know just killing mass amounts of
slow-moving AI they like I guess one of
the visual departments like hey we can
like put like a zombie face on it it's
like okay cool yeah and then some
partners like yeah we can do like a like
a zombie noise on it like okay cool and
then next thing and they know they're
showing it to like Activision execs hey
Activision can we do this and then
activations like yeah we keep playing so
yeah like yeah we got to like level 12
or whatever it is um yeah it's you know
it's I don't know I don't know if I
thirty bucks is pretty steep I feel like
because you know these games are very
centered on obviously playing with I
mean like my opinion friends I don't
know like if people I'm sure people are
like playing like online with randoms
but I don't know I think it's a little
steep but it's it's definitely fun and
it's nice to go back to like again like
the totin map which I have played hours
and hours and hours with my buddy in
college and it's nice like the
remastered value is cool like they did a
lot of lighting and they were messed our
all of the sound effects are not all of
a lot of sound effects right still very
creepy sounding models guns they added
only a handful of the original weapon
because you're really playing with the
black ops 3 arsenal yeah so I mean that
you can see in the gameplay here like
Jake picked up like a nice ER which is
the actually one of my load outs in
black ops 3 so I was pretty stoked
because I was like I can actually shoot
things
effectively yeah bro some maps where you
have like regular revolvers and stuff
brown proud 23 in the YouTube shadow
just wondering why it's the futuristic
weapons in these World War 2 settings
but it is the black ops 3 weapons
correct yes not going back to world war
stuff that will exam it's it's a it's a
slight mix oh like for instance in the
tone map like you still have the Thunder
gun the Raygun and monkeys like a couple
of things
naturally yeah the monkeys man you know
you know you know each others are
monkeys learning yeah you throw a monkey
and it's basically it's the classic like
um monkey monkey symbol yeah were for
the zombies and then explodes but you
would throw it always you got it because
was so key and if you went down I could
throw it and just the amount times like
again like my buddy would be throw it
like yelling it it's funny lobbies is
fun I actually I you know we're lucky
enough to have copies of it but I really
want to play that map again with just
you guys cuz it's yes it was fun to have
that super fun I think it's also worth
noting that um they included like a mix
of maps designed to be for both like
veteran zombies players and people who
hadn't played zombies before um so
there's like a mix of harder and like
origins is in here I love zombies in
Call of Duty games they are very very
complex once you get into them and when
you my friends and I actually used to
play with like random people and then
every once a while you get someone who
really knew what they were doing and you
would figure out the best route through
these doors when to spend your money
here how to upgrade this weapon how to
get to the pack-a-punch machine the best
paths yeah and and I really like the the
factory that's the first one I think the
head pack was gonna mean I believe mundo
vasa the electric yeah that was Shino
numa's in this the swamp with the that's
I think there's the third ever or maybe
there's the second I don't know but yeah
it's yeah I think it's yeah I think that
means zombie swamp in Japanese
apparently mmm she she is like the word
for death so oh maybe that's um
swamp yeah don't quote us on that um
yeah shangri-la is in here which isn't
one of my favorites but and personally
at zombies like again the older maps uh
I like a lot more than any of the the
latest iterations because I just I
prefer the simplicity of it just you
know they didn't I think a lot in my
opinion some B's gets kind of carried
away sometimes there's so many different
things and factors as far as like
different types of perks like at one
point Jake was a zombie himself when we
were playing yesterday so they yep I
notice that so Jake they implemented the
the gobblegum
which you see around here and I is that
actually what it's called yes yeah uh I
did the less layers for me in it in a
zombie game I have more fun because it's
just as core it's just about like you
know finding that route that path and
and living that panic induce life of
waiting that's my real nothing one yeah
I was about to say that's me awesome
what about is five the Pentagon one in
here it smell like what black ops one's
a Pentagon Trejo on the arctic with
Johnny Trejo no moon isn't here uh she
no name in shangri-la or totin born with
Z that I can't different leaders there
right the that's the tone one yeah Oh
God ascension um yeah origins someone a
lot of my had actually not played um so
what schools we should definitely play
this like maybe later on today after
work or something cuz I would absolutely
do that like playing these and screwing
people or well remember we were doing we
were we played I forgot what the context
was but Nick and I were having
competition where you go for ten seconds
and then you pause it and give it to the
controller someone else so I would just
run into a crowd of zombies pause it and
give it to him try to [ __ ] him over yeah
yeah it $30 yeah black ops three you
also need black ops three I'd say you
know this yeah and I'd say you know if
you are a really hardcore zombies fan
and I know there are those people and
you have black ops three I could very
well be worth it
um any trejo yeah several things Jake
already corrected you my bad
uh yeah that zombies baby yeah there's a
huge zombies community I really get
fascinated with that stuff but also I
think before he left obviously Scott
Butterworth did a feature on the making
of zombies was pretty interesting like
you would mention how it was kind of a
happy accident right but yeah this is a
$30 for a PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC
no I'll let appeals oh that's good
question and I think it I was so focused
on looking up the maps that I cuz it
definitely also on Xbox one yet yeah I
guess so I don't know look that up um oh
yeah you did you guys play zombies in
space land at all yeah like that was
like that a lot I believe fun I played a
lot of that with my brother that was I
believe the first zombies that Infinity
Ward did it yes ah cuz they did with
what was their past game ghost they did
that escalation I think yeah that was
their first foray into zombies it looks
like it's like the the aesthetic
I love the eighties it actually looks
like it's just on ps4 yeah that's what I
thought oh yeah yeah whoo Google yeah
that makes sense Activision's called
threes get been kind of supporting Sony
more yeah or vice versa but yeah let's
go check this out if you want to if
you're really into playing all these
having all eight maps in one place on
ps4 remastered I think that checks out
he yelled at us and was like guys the
teleporters those yeah these moments are
fun where Jake said Jake had set up the
teleporter here if you know this man oh
it's so part of teleporters you know you
don't just do it all willy-nilly you got
to wait for a whole group of zombies to
come and we were just being stupid and
it wasn't working so we're all like
cornered in the teleport screaming this
gets terrifying if you're by yourself
like look I think that's whoever's on
stage under my tag is gonna die right on
there by themselves yeah Rob's F I think
he did die oh I remember this moment cuz
I was I was talking to uh yeah the dev
and I was like yeah you know dogs are
pretty tricky as long as you keep your
mind on them and don't let yourself slip
and then as I'm saying is I though I'd
Abba there's overwhelming ages laughing
I have the regen so I was doing alright
anyway I think it's worth it just for
that kind of if you have friends to play
with your friends who also like zombies
just in conclusion any FPS for and you
have black ops 3 yeah
it
it was a lot of fun this seems like the
perfect thing right now in between all
these games I'm trying to finish these
long-form things for some of five prey
I'm gonna start firing them soon this
seems like a good palate cleanser mm-hmm
yeah we should play that later but on -
we have Joey he's here in the studio
he's not miked up but he's back there
he's one of our more prolific fighting
heat wave lawyers he's waving at the
wall ah but he's behind our he's behind
our camera right now he's gonna be
playing injustice too while we talk
about it a game that generally across
the office I think even people who are
not traditional fighting game fans sorry
are not traditionally fighting game fans
are really enjoying it myself included
but Pete you gave it a 9 out of 10 you
betcha
were you surprised me yeah I was I don't
like when I'm on the same wavelength as
you like stop thinking my thoughts no
get away from my brain gold mother box
what is that your gold mother has given
you a box mmm
I saw Joey's gonna what you gonna jump
into the multiverse all right Pete
monitors what is this it's a multiverse
is a place where events are randomly
generated and an event can include a
series of fights and then there are
rewards that are pitched to you the
characters you fight can come in various
different levels and wear different gear
as he Joey's upset cuz he got some bad
modifiers so characters have different
levels and can wear geared up grade
their stats but modifiers are the thing
that make these fights super interesting
beyond difficulty because they change
things like environmental effects
physics rules controls even they can be
really annoying or they can be super
beneficial but instead of having this
variety that's regenerated on a hourly
daily or weekly basis is kind of
interesting and it's a great way to earn
rewards in the form of experience points
in gear gear being the thing that is
going to give this game longevity I
think for you know outside of the
competitive community who's going to
tear it apart and play strategically and
learn how to do that
the Metaverse and the gear will keep I
think more casual and average players
excited I think that this looks really
hot so fast because that's a modified
smart but yeah this is not how I
remember the game yesterday but
what is black Canary's power what did
she do she yells yells there I was but
say one of her finishers or what do a
super right I basically like throws a
guy down on the ground gets over him it
just does her teaching yell to him and
he's just like freaking out isn't there
an x-men character that does that to
Banshee Banshee yeah I think so
this x-men right sure yeah market is I'm
sure it's a really bad car hey I'm
really so we want to talk about the
roster obviously that's the main appeal
for a lot of people Joey's are you
scarecrow or black Mary joey is
scarecrow that's a character he's been
playing a lot and I believe at this
point in the multiverse you have the
gear and everything right so yes in the
multiverse and in plenty of modes you
have the gear but most importantly the
gear stat boosts count here because
you're going up against enemies that
maybe have time much higher level than
you or they have really strong gear and
that helps kind of keep the variety
going and the you know the impetus to to
really look forward to gear and where
your best stuff it's really only you can
see the gear in any mode it's just the
stats are not active by default anytime
in ranked match yes
so ranked matches are the competitive
stuff there's no option stats but you
can wear your gear unranked battles
players can decide for themselves if
they want stats hmm to carry over or not
what is gravity flux what's that
modifier uh that might make jumping a
little bit different I mean I haven't
seen all the modifiers I draw faster
like more graph drop faster you might
jump higher you might cover more ground
I'm not sure good fight Joey yeah it's
well done Joey uh so Joey's scarecrow
right here ostensibly would look very
different from someone else's dirty
sociopathic legs of terror yes so yeah
these characters will look different
cool start answering your question uh
yeah I'm really I love the idea of
spending like a weekend with one
character just learning their moves but
also getting some cool-looking gear and
some gear that's gonna help me out
further down the road and that's really
appealing to me I like that there are
RPG mechanics in this because we're
those present in the first and justice
No okay
and so but there are some complications
that are worth talking about dude that
vomits on proccess yeah does the bars
blood into people's face to make them
comply that's so hot
nice way of laying that out yeah so yet
this game uses a lot of different
currency systems to manage the
purchasing regeneration and modifying of
gear and one of the complications
therein that's not currency is the level
lock for gear so you get a lot of stuff
in the story mode that looks really cool
but you can't wear it until your little
twenty and son all gear but that's some
stuff and that sort of makes you feel
like well crap I've got this thing but I
can't wear it so the thing that you use
where you can either level up a
character automatically or change the
appearance of one type of gear to that
of another gosh the cat I'm explaining a
very complex system I'm sorry we're not
paying any attention but I can't
interrupting lying I don't know where
this Christ keep going anyway this game
long story short this game is really
good at tempting you to spend real-world
money you don't have to do it to get a
lot out of it I didn't spend any and I
enjoy the process of getting Superman up
to level 20 a few other characters up to
level 10 as I did that I earned more
gear I had access to more the gear I
already owned but it certainly is a
practice that is very obviously done to
tempt you into this necessary evil of
paid for its Simon DLC it's just like
paid for unlocks there's stuff that you
own in the game and it seems very weird
but that's really only the bad thing I
can say about injustice to it it's
otherwise a really great fighting game I
mean I'm not on evil level at all
anywhere close in any fighting game
series but I've played them since I can
remember and I typically love Japanese
games more often because I'd like the
flow of something like Street Fighter 5
versus the very deliberate staccato pace
of this game but once you the inputs are
so easy that once you actually start
playing for a while you see how to link
things together and what was worth what
was that first stiff and awkward becomes
pretty fluid after a while so that's
really good it's got an amazing story
mode the best cinematic work nether
realms ever done especially red the oh
yeah especially the face animation yeah
it's top-notch I've never see a it's
hard to a think of a game other than
like Metal Gear Solid 5 or Uncharted
that really does mouth movements and
speech as well there was there was a
gift flowing round of
Quinn uh I feel other to uh heroes like
looking through a window and she was
chewing gum and talking and it just
looked like a filter on an actual like
right shot of someone like doing just
that like it was saying it seems like
they actually did motion capture for
bodies in the mouth but like all the
movement in the face like in the eyes
and the brow that almost that all seems
to be done just by hand in the computer
I don't know for certain but if so
that's a really interesting creative
approach because I think the mouth is
often the most awkward thing right it
also be super expressive in a comic book
universe that's gonna be your brow right
that's going to be things like that like
so it's a really interesting mix of the
two for all I know it could be all
facial capture but these look great yeah
as far as one dumb why aren't you saying
I'm taking you now uh what can you say
as far as like myself not being like
anything remotely close to like a
fighting game player but like what would
you you mentioned like basically a
learning curve yeah like how long in do
you think well we get to the comfortable
factor and away from the button mashing
yeah that's a really good question I
mean so part of that is figuring out
what character you actually like yeah so
the story mode rolls out I'd say almost
half the cast and gives you a chance to
play them for a couple rounds and you
can get kind of the taste there but you
know it's once you start going into the
multiverse that you sort of start seeing
different ways of training the modifiers
actually teach you how to use characters
in different ways right and so if
there's one where you can't jump then
you start to think about like okay what
do I do if I'm not jumping and attacking
from overhead you're using blocks and
other things sure yeah so it or it
organically gives you experience in
terms of like how characters behave but
going back to the move lists they're
very they're very simple to understand
so once you start to memorize those
moves and you get comfortable performing
them you know one move at a time you
then start to just feel that innate
confidence that comes from just pulling
off something and going to the next move
right away I don't I think if you spent
like a handful of hours like
beat the story mode you know understand
the mechanics of the game like the
general way that every character works
and then you could just spend a couple
hours with another one in the Metaverse
and you'd probably start to see a lot of
progress hmm
I mean I take two Capcom's games kind of
like water these game nether realms
games have always been difficult for me
but this has been the easiest for me to
get into oh yeah sure
it seems really accessible but you said
it was like even if from whether you're
a hardcore fighting fan or someone like
me who I'm getting into it almost it's
introducing me to a ton of DC that I was
not familiar yeah I give a [ __ ] about DC
that's nice but here I am that was my
next question cuz I am neither a
fighting game person or a DC person like
the only thing I really care about is
Batman yeah um but I'm really intrigued
especially with the quality of the
cinematic work like I might actually
kind of get into these characters a
little bit more and kind of is it a good
introduction to the characters if you
are it is a good introduction to a
twisted version of most of his
characters just i li explained the
purpose of restoring girlfriends the
premise of the story is that in the last
game that superman was tricked into
killing Lois Lane setting off a nuclear
bomb in Metropolis subsequently he is
just pissed at the world he's done being
mr. nice guy
he wants to murder every criminal he
wants to kill them wipe them off the
face of the earth
Batman is like whoa dude I don't kill I
don't think we should kill it super his
basic just I will screw you homey and
like so the rest of the game you know
there's a threat that appears some guys
trying to you know absorb the earth take
all its knowledge well blah blah blah
but the sort of conflict between Batman
and Superman is really interesting so to
watch Superman be so hell bent on
murdering anyone who might be a criminal
and becoming this like totalitarian
leader that's super interesting
regardless if you care about DC Comics
and like the intricacies you know that
have been around for a while because we
all have an idea of Superman right right
clean-cut Clark Kent nice guy whatever
no he just wants to kill people but did
they've done a crime or not that's all I
mean and you know say what you will
about the last movies like it's tough to
represent Superman he's kind of like an
old archaic comic book-y a hero so and
he still has that like that friendly
confidence when he talks about killing
people it's like Jesus kind of cool
Superman always like ends up boring me
right yeah directly I didn't think I
would care yeah I really enjoyed it
uh yeah it's what intrigues me too is I
don't want to say it's immersive but it
were it really works right like you
would just imagine like a comic book and
what if these superheroes were matched
with each other and then and that is so
well represented with the cinematics and
those like super moves uh it's just it's
got his level of like epicness I guess
yeah that is really engaging part of
that's due to nether realms hand here
because there are some like if you look
at the the plot points that bring some
of these characters together in the
story mode like outside of Batman and
Superman it's kind of like yeah I see
you guys you know this is an excuse for
you to bring these characters together
the story reason doesn't make much sense
but it's all elevated by nether realms
ability to sort of like you know stir up
drama and like darkness and kind of like
you know conflict and stuff so it
NetherRealm deserves a lot of credit for
what they've done here with DC's
properties absolutely yeah and the maps
I think are really well done and X in
their execution of like there was like
the training mode was basically all I've
gone into so far has like you know
Batman and Superman out on the street I
just love the cinematic value of this
like a spotlight comes on from a
helicopter looking at you and it's like
yeah this kind of feels like again like
like a cinematic experience like
everyone is watched watching this epic
fight uh and here maybe not so much in a
bar which is funny but like I love those
scene changes to how you can do that
that seems it's just fun to watch yeah
do you have any characters that you what
are your favorite characters that you
put been playing uh so I because I was
trying to hit level 20 I played Superman
a lot because through the story mode
there's like level 9 or 10 so basic
anyway so I like Superman and it's it's
fun too because you unlock new abilities
for characters as you level up so you
can actually add to your repertoire and
then customize it when they have more
than a couple slots to like your actual
move us yeah oh cool yeah dog
uh so yeah I kind of enjoyed Superman I
got one move added to his move list that
made him even more fun for me but I've
also been playing as Robin who in this
case is Batman's son Damian Wayne kind
of [ __ ] sword - he's got like a
katana and he's really interesting
because he his moves have a lot of
variations to them so one move can you
can control it to either go standard
distance short distance or long distance
and your enemy might not notice it when
you pull it off until you're like in
that animation already and they're under
attack
likewise he's you know every character
has a character trait with the press of
the circle button they can get like a
buff or they can call in like an assist
character his is he throws a Batarang
into the ground depending on what other
button he put he presses while hitting
circle he can either teleport to that
Batarang battering can attack someone
else or can explode as like a smoke
screen oh wow yeah so he is really fun
cuz he's one of those characters that is
deceptive right and that's kind of what
I like to do I'd like enlike el fuerte
from Street Fighter 4 if you ever played
that character and he's like a little
bit unpredictable they move very
differently but the nature of how they
fight come along those lines
Robin looks like someone I was like I
was telling you I'm not really good at
I'm not good at fighting game so I need
someone with a reach yeah so I don't
have to worry about my positioning as
much it mate looks like scarecrow might
be pretty good with that scarecrow is
good his his hook and chain pretty easy
to get like moves that'll give you space
Superman though has very easy
projectiles that you can throw across
the screen mm-hmm
of course there are characters such as
scarecrow who can teleport by going
underground and appearing somewhere else
and so you know there's ways to get
around that yeah there's there's 28
characters here Darkseid costs money at
launch which some people are upset about
other people are upset that I think
there's like six characters that are
announced for DLC so far and kind of
like a oh nine and kind of like Mortal
Kombat X you know there's going to be a
version this game that has all the
characters but as we've seen with
campaigns like that of Skullgirls one
character in a fighting game can cost a
couple hundred thousand
dollars to produce yeah so with 28 here
and a huge variety among that cast to me
I don't think it's that bad that they
have these characters coming down the
road [ __ ] you know it's there's so much
to see already and this game just has so
many modes I think whether you're like a
hardcore you know competitive player or
a novice right just like you know keep
yourself going yes the gear system
currencies stop a [ __ ] but outside of
that I'd say this is a you know a very
robust fighting game and perhaps one of
the most robust um sense a game like oh
yeah there's lot of weird fighting games
out there with adventure modes I'll just
leave it at that yeah I mean you saw it
was awesome you said in a lot of ways
this feels like what another realm has
been working toward with their games
even like with Mortal Kombat X
absolutely I mean the the roots in
Mortal Kombat are very evident in this
and in the first injustice but you know
like they've gotten rid of things like
QuickTime events in cinematics right
like I think that's the thing that
people complain about they persisted
with for a while to not see them here as
like they must have listened because
clearly they thought that was a good
idea and their audience told them
otherwise yeah I mean there's just so
much to it like even the multiverse in
Mortal Kombat that was the living tower
but there was also this like weird like
thing are you exploring graveyards and
Mortal Kombat X in like a first-person
mode and like getting into it was just
strange this is sort of like you could
see how they've taken those pieces
looked at them critically and found out
okay how do we put these together so
it's not this convoluted weird way of
giving people more to do yeah how does
it make sense in the context of this
world and in what people actually want
from the game do we know who those nine
characters are gonna be I can think of a
few cuz Nightwing's not in this yet
right which is weird
well like night I think Nightwing is you
fight him in the game I think he's a
alternate skin because once you equip
sets of gear for certain characters they
can have new abilities or transform in
in the kind of subtle ways but yes he's
different than Robin but I kind of fight
similar to Robin he's an alternate skin
for Robin I think so
Lorelei's doesn't that not make sense
wasn't yeah like Damian wasn't night
wasn't Nightwing I tell you what is he
know he's got an alternate skin it's not
an alternate
skin as much as you get the weapon and
he fights more like Nightwing doesn't he
use like so that's the two short staff
things isn't that basically just an
alternate skin god yeah that's weird
I'd rather have you know he's at what a
he's getting at what I'm getting at is
he's not a separate character
Deathstroke's I'm in this either ah no
so you're gonna see like red hood
sub-zero for Mortal Kombat's coming over
it's a couple more I just can't remember
red hood was what's his name wasn't that
Dick Grayson revived I thought about the
Robin Hood died I don't know
hmm no I want to play Green Arrow I like
Green Arrow the first game a lot like
guys can have different elemental arrows
and stuff there's a I've never heard of
Captain cold before in my life yeah I
also yeah cheetah so Captain Cold has
the odd myth we have a video on on
gamespot.com
explaining who cheetah is yeah um you
mentioned like QuickTime events which
bruise I was from the last game right
yes it was in the last game and it was
in Mortal Kombat X as well it is it
taken form into that clash system that
keep seeing pop up you know when I say
QuickTime events I meant like during
cutscenes in the story mode those wagers
oh okay sorry
those wagers are you can initiate them
and then you bank your what you want to
call it your meter and thank you me your
meaning so wager you wager it right so
essentially you know you each have like
let's say four meters right yeah four
sections if you wager for the other
person wagers to you're going to win the
clash but depending on if you're the
attacker or the defender you're either
going to take off your opponent's health
or you're going to regain some health
yourself but the sort of risk they're in
is that you're cashing in meter and the
more media meter you have the more ways
you have to get out of combos the more
ways you have to do powered up super
moves right so it's sort of like a
give-and-take and there's a mind game
because you don't know what the other
person is doing it's it's a pretty
interesting system honestly it's sort of
it's very unconventional how do you
engage that so once you lose the first
half of your meter which is like the
gray portion and you're down the red
right then it's just a matter of using
the l2 button and I forget the other one
but yeah that triggers it you can each
only do it once per fight and again only
when you're on your second health bar
well what is it can you do green arrows
super-move Joe nevermind what is this
oh no I've seen any shoots the is that
they have something to the Apple was
that just his victory thing maybe that's
his victory yeah he shoots an apple in
there maybe there's an intro or
something I don't know um
yeah I'm really gonna I want to keep
playing this are you still like learning
any characters or you have you kind of
had to move on to a new game for review
or anything there's actually just been a
lot of reviews to manage since I put
this review up um but no I want to keep
playing as Robin I really like his
character and now that there's more
people playing and the game will be out
tomorrow that right it's already out I
came out yesterday are ya yeah um Zoltar
there it's more people to play yeah
that's I say it does look like Zoltan I
said um yeah I wanna I want to find like
a three or four characters I really like
and try to get good with them I'm really
stoked for Tekken 7 though that's not
looking forward to what is that out June
early June first week of June yeah what
it is is that the only oh and then mob
what's it Marvel and Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite whatever yeah that's called and
those that the Capcom fighting games are
kind of much faster paced right not as
stiff as nothing realms right but the
upcoming one is dumbed down yeah so but
this is accessible it seems like nether
realm made this accessible in a really
good way that doesn't sacrifice the
hardcore totally yeah I think it's just
tough as [ __ ] to do
yeah like I've played some people online
that I just I can't believe the things
they're doing and it's like they must
feel happy with this game because
they're doing some impressive [ __ ] yeah
it was also something a scrub like me
could pick up yeah and just enjoy it
even if you're not on a competitive
level yeah and they're actually just the
last thing I'll mention there is a way
to so-called compete without actually
fighting so the characters that you
build and raise you can build a team
that fight as AI so three characters you
upload them to the server you can
challenge other people's characters and
if you win those fights which are
automated you can get some rewards every
day and then people can challenge you
when you're not playing and so you want
you actually watch the fights that you
initiate play out and you can like
fast-forward them up to like four times
normal speed if you want no way but
school but you think about it this way
right like yeah you can't pull off like
an infinite combo
or whatever in a fight but you have
built a squad of Fighters that's really
good and can still take someone down
even if you're not absolutely in control
of it that's awesome it's not something
for everyone but it's something for
people who are intimidated by
traditional online like me you're you're
legitimately watching oh this is ever
here you're watching it another guy and
you can see so Godzilla was a bad man
similarly it is is getting rekt yeah I
mean you can play this at normal speed
but it's also fun to do it at fast
forward because you know that's another
person I'm so sorry I interrupted
another person's team that they've
uploaded to a strategy so this is all AI
oh okay oh I thought I was an actual
person okay and then yeah you can get
like up to five item boxes a day whether
you're attacking or defending but you
also do earn experience for these fights
so like when I was doing my review and
need to level up Superman when I learned
that I was like I'll shoot I can go make
dinner and level up Superman by like
every 30 seconds looking at my ps4 and
like hitting X a couple times yeah you
don't get a lot of experience it's not
like you can really like fudge it but
it's enough to make incremental
differences especially when you're at a
lower level it's like a kind of a what
do you want to say like a JRPG that you
can automate stuff like that battles
about to say it sounds like the gambits
and final fantasy 12 you don't have much
control over how they fight okay that's
the that's the primary difference there
so it's just like you've built up this
character you've leveled up this
character and you kind of send them off
to do work for you while you're not
playing yes the one thing that's a
little inconvenient with this is that
they will retain the levels that you've
given them I believe automatically but
if you equip items to characters outside
of the AI battles and you go into the AI
battle you have to reconstruct your
team's loadout because it's all saved on
a server it doesn't transfer
automatically and maybe you want to have
characters that are equipped differently
than the ones you're using outside of it
so you just have to keep that in mind
like there were a few fights that got in
AI battles where I was like oh crap this
build is hours old like I didn't intend
for that to happen but you're not really
losing much if you lose you lose thirty
seconds of your time and whatever as a
fighting game had something like this
before not that I can think of but I
they're very well could be what about
people who care about
right right forehead always rainbow I
always like to think of smash in a
separate category than I think of a game
like this I never kind of associate them
yeah I was questioning in my head when I
was closing on my review like you know
yes this is a game that has something
for everyone
isn't that smash but I think for smash
it's so much about competition this
offers a lot of different pursuits where
it's not just whether you win or lose it
makes you feel happy about playing the
game
smash also lacks a lot of the RPG
progression at this game well of course
of course
um that's the stuff yeah uh yeah I
really want to play more of this I
definitely want to try out like flash
green arrow uh I don't know I kinda
wanna see what captain colds deal is cuz
I you know like to replace mr. freeze
what do you gotta have a good excuse
though there is a scheme good for mr.
freeze okay gotcha listen go uh your
review is up nine out of ten on GameSpot
you want to read that yeah buddy you
don't want to read it probably you wrote
it I did I wrote it with my girlfriend
playing black desert online behind me
with her two friends without a headset
so I had three voices talking in my ear
the whole time nice but somehow I wrote
a review yeah you played all weekend I
put yeah I've been playing since
Wednesday Thursday and yeah this weekend
if I wasn't writing I was playing cool
so you can go check that out if you're
watching right now you know read that on
GameSpot UH one last thing that I want
to talk about before we close at the
show people were talking on the chat but
they announced a Witcher series for
Netflix yeah
I'll watch that based on your novels not
the game right so there it's its pre
game right priest um prequel if you will
previous know that what the UH
that's what the games are we're sorry
the books are about right
it's like think so they didn't they
introduced the characters The Witcher 3
expands upon them
Jennifer Cirie Gerald yeah we should we
should uh you should review you should
review the series as if it's a game that
uh okay that's interesting that Netflix
is like yeah like they're trying to get
into that like you know fantasy Lord the
Rings style maybe I Game of Thrones was
one getting at it and now it's like
Witcher
they're bankrolling anime to death no
the crunchy rolling anime no no don't
we're funding funding original oh yeah
yeah I have made their own original
anime which means it's it's like it's
complicated I don't want to get into it
right now get into it I have a lot of
thoughts I've got something to summarize
them right now
it's not fast I love it yeah it's just
it's hard to call something the term
anime the definition of anime is very
complicated and so it's like an anime
style show that's not technically anime
depends on who works on if it's Japanese
origin let's talk about the timing at
the RPG you all work yeah there's a lot
of things anyway uh anime and manga are
the same thing right uh-huh
I'm leaving uh do you really wanna get
into the term GRP right now I've done it
many times yeah I'll do whenever we just
rather calm RPGs yes there's some anime
for you there it's a nice drawing that
Rob made for me can get it up on the
camera there cut to a different camera
it's supposed to be meeting my bus it
says my butt smells can you do that okay
yeah would you guys lay in the rest the
week uh Lee Fire Emblem I kind of want
to review the game it's been a while and
justice was good I want a kid to do in a
while since you reviewed a game that the
review went up Monday it's been two days
no but just my first to know know what
yeah oh I didn't listen at all no sorry
what about you two cally what you
playing I'm still playing pray last
night
I was still looking for the shotgun and
I just discovered that I misunderstood
where it was supposed to be and I that's
how I cleared the neuro mod division and
didn't find the shotgun oh there's a
bunch of shotguns I know but I know
where the first one is but I thought it
I misunderstood the infection I didn't
get mine too like 15 hours in oh well
I'm pretty far in but I cleared the
entire endure about division and I got
some cool fabrication plans so cleared
it for now oh you got there the aliens
come back in like these no I know
there's AK there's a couple places
Leslie I don't have like the mimic
ability yet so there's a couple places I
couldn't get into yeah but anyway I'm
gonna be playing that and also um I
still haven't beaten Zelda such
yeah the LC comes out in this this
summer right June I will put money on it
that in ten is gonna drop it at e3 and
we're all gonna quit why we're all gonna
panic and in ten is gonna sit back in
the treehouse but we're just gonna play
the new DLC all day long all y'all can F
yourselves or play it whatever like yeah
I expected to drop during e3 cool uh
you've been oddly quiet at the last few
minutes his jaw hurts your jaw people
are talking I'm not gonna talk over them
that's rude okay now all sudden because
it matters what do you playing this week
uh I really all that injustice talk
coming all riled up I want to play that
game to write bad I thought that you're
gonna do jump all that injustice talk
really makes me want to play fire emblem
I want play battlegrounds people are
talking about battlegrounds yeah and I
see gameplay and it looks really fun
yeah yeah we we have got to play that
and do like a stream yeah that's
definitely happened down the road I also
yeah I got you just said pray I was like
oh my god that's right there's just
there's so many games this year it's
freaking insane and they're all they're
like okay I got a play persona still I
haven't like really made a big dent in
persona what you want to just I wrote
down my backlog in my notes it's
depressing to look at I don't usually
keep a backlog but this year
specifically it's actually a lot of good
games I want to finish neo I want to
finish near I want to go back and play
resin evil 7 for the third time I want
to play fire emblem now I want to play
more injustice - I want a beat Zelda I
wanna play eyes I have to beat persona 5
- oh my god see
and then 30 I was making on top of that
there's like several anime I need to
catch up on and watch Twin Peaks and
that's Sunday so I want to catch up
before the new one comes out yeah
because I wasn't alive when it came out
so I just watch it yo you haven't
watched it at all no I watched like like
5s yeah oh dude the second season gets
so drawn-out but the payoff that's cute
someone described I think with the
second season there's like 22 episodes
that's all right yeah someone described
it as 9 good episodes and then another
unnecessary 13 yeah it does this thing
we're kind of like tries to mimic
whether intentional or not mimic like a
soap opera type feel and it just kind of
gets overwrought in its own style that
has
beware I dropped off yeah I don't have
to be people are always like oh yeah you
can skip certain episodes I don't
believe in skipping episodes so I will
watch them it stuff it the thing is the
payoff is so cathartic like coming off
of that sort of like the payoff is so
strange it's just so like I can't even
if even if I described it it wouldn't do
it justice yeah I will say the second
season has a really interesting like
opening moments that that's really good
is the the Sunday drop is that one
episode is that the whole season I
actually don't know it's been trying
I've been avoiding every gonna be the
whole season like it like I think I
might have been spoiled for Twin Peaks
on Twitter so I just been avoiding Twin
Peaks entirely because I just don't want
to know but then I'm also so bad I've
been procrastinating watching it yeah
it's it's a hard show to get through
especially if you're trying to like
binge watch it yeah I started a while
ago and it's just such a slow drip is it
is it Netflix actually I said yes yeah I
don't turn to second-guess myself god I
had to have been I don't know I I
wouldn't have washed it any other way
it's also no I mean like the new season
uh-oh
that's good question I went to Twin
Peaks last week yeah here in San
Francisco
yeah the most exposure I've had to that
it's not Showtime it's on Showtime thank
you John Luke weird you could subscribe
to that without having cable I think
yeah it's like a lot of people subscribe
to stars recently because of American
Gods which apparently is that good
I know Pizza really good yeah a lot of
covers on that in games by universe
can't you get Showtime through Hulu or
is that something else that might piece
yes noise I think stars is like weirdly
through Amazon's
yes and stars also has don't they have
um ash vs. Evil Dead yes they do which
is a pretty decent show yeah they have a
lot of bees on there I love Evil Dead so
that is oh yeah before we go I also want
to talk about new stream Robin I have
gone home oh god yeah starting tomorrow
do spoil the name you didn't you did not
spoil it in the tweet yeah you can shout
it out my friend Dino DNA we came up
with that name and that bad way of
saying it you did I got City royal T so
yes
shout that explain it uh we're gonna um
if you watch Triforce Rob and I had fun
just sort of dickin around in that game
Zelda we're looking for an excuse just
to get together and keep [ __ ] around
and I was drunk and thought hey why not
games about dinosaurs and Rob took the
bait
so here we are I took it I was in Tahoe
and I saw a nice one
like what Dino Crisis that Jurassic Park
am what I want there so many Lost Ark
are in the first far cry have Raptors
we're gonna find out haha you should
find out next week what is then it
starts tomorrow at 11 a.m. a Pacific
time specifically Pacific time and we
are going to start with uh tell tales
Jurassic Park the game sweet oh yeah
it's gonna be fun well by the way as
we're playing the game when we see a
dinosaur we're going to have facts on
the dice where Rob and I are already
experts we already kind of know
everything so we will teach you there
back checking these games is what it is
right okay cool I'm interested oh if you
see a triceratops just just you're gonna
three horns what's the one with the by
Sara tops what's the one who look at
that fans out its its head if Andres car
top source is a zipless is the
Diplodocus meat-eater
okay not a carnivore is my Newman yo
Simon when I went away you're talking
about hello oh my god hello Newman
undirected Jeff Goldblum if you're
watching please come on the show yeah
we're out there Jeff he's gonna come on
Jeff Goldblum is uh Dylan Klein in the
YouTube chat that's actually general
yeah play Dino Christ that game is
actually kind of fun but the first ones
alright do never do never do not ever
play not like do never do never play
Dino Crisis three well now I'm going to
on Xbox the original Xbox you have a
jetpack
yep dinosaurs spawn infinitely yeah uh
like in front of you tell me something
that's gonna not make me want to play
the dinosaurs are wholly inaccurate okay
I think the favorite my favorite lead
I've ever written for
view was when I was a freelancer with
and I wrote a review for carnivores
dinosaur hunter - or something like that
that's the way my lead was Tyrannosaurus
Rex Rex that pretty good speaking of
livestreams at 2:00 today actually Nick
margarita I mentions the beginning the
show but Nick margarita and Richie here
will be playing Farpoint the VR shooter
for PlayStation VR so come check that
out here on Twitch or YouTube or
GameSpot's player wherever you happen to
be watching right now
I think Jeff Goldblum will be on that
stream as well if you see what he's
doing lately playing Farpoint well no I
mean other than that no he's been
running a sausage truck like a food
truck selling sausages yeah
I'm not joking I'm not questioning you
all right that sounds like go on gravy
is he touring he in for the new Thor
right yes and he plays this like very
well flamboyantly flat fashioned like I
don't know he's some part of the
government
he just looks ridiculous that guy is
great yeah he's really good uh cool as
always everybody thank you for joining
on twitch YouTube or GameSpot thank you
to Richard Lee Eric taejeon leukocyte
key in the back Joey thank you for
playing in justice to today and winning
most of your matches I saw that one loss
don't you forget it
but as always thank you for joining us
we would back next time we're getting
closer to e3 so it's gonna start getting
busy we'll be back next Wednesday 11:00
a.m. Pacific I'll see you then bye Hey
you
[Music]
you